I did recently just this past weekend
which I was I'm psyched about I did I
went on to insta live have you done that
Conan I don't think I've done that I've
done a ton of zoom and I've done some
Skype what's insta live well I'm not
sure but I went on it it's on Instagram
I love I love your you bring it up I
asked you what it is long ties idea get
Mark Zuckerberg on here he can tell you
but I will say that you've pushed the
thing and then you're live on your on
your Instagram feed and and then you can
have a conversation with somebody anyway
what we did was I'd never done it before
did an insta Life conversation with Tony
Hale to discuss the pilot of veep
because HBO is streaming all of this
material for free right now including
our show and so I thought oh that'd be
fun and a good way to raise money for
Direct Relief which is this organization
that's on the providing support to the
front the workers on the front lines
health care workers and so we did it and
we have this goal to raise you know
we're hoping we might raise $10,000 and
we raised $25,000 yeah both yeah I know
I heard about this you doubled what you
were trying to achieve fantastic yeah
Direct Relief which is a really good
cause and I'm gonna put that down I'm
not gonna do it someone much smarter
than me is putting that information
right now on the bottom this is a great
cause it is a great cause
yes we've got this great GoFundMe page
you they can find it on my something in
there yeah you're pointing to my
computer your technical terminology is
awful but we're gonna get the word out
please tell me that's gin you betcha I
know you seem kind of loose you seem
super loose I like it